[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations
being the best brigade this is the final
dinner but tonight
the stakes are even higher because those
guys out there are gonna be the toughest
ever customers we've cooked for it's the
first time i've filled the ration up
with 50 vegetarians all wanted to be
converted to eating meat
this quite frankly is one of the most
important meals you'll ever cook because
if we [ __ ] this
up you'll spoil their hopes are becoming
meat eaters
now there's pressure yes are you ready
for the challenge yes i'm always ready
now what's the menu mel um lobster and
potatoes
we have a really expensive looking
canvas we're not allowed to waste
yeah an amazing farm caviar yeah tastes
like it's extraordinary stuff
now before we start cooking yeah i want
you to understand
where it's come from yeah have a quick
look at this on there
one of my favorite ingredients in the
world sums up food at its finest
and most prestigious caviar
very decadent very nutty very creamy
and it's bursting with flavour like
individual pearls exploding in your
mouth
absolutely delicious but classic wild
caviar is under threat
sturgeon and the caspian sea are
overfished and close to extinction
so the hunt is on to find alternatives
fast
so i'm looking for something sustainable
and affordable to blow beluga out of the
water when it comes to taste
and texture i'm not gonna find it in
[ __ ] knightsbridge
i've come to andalusia in southern spain
which for the past 25 years
has hidden one of the mediterranean's
best kept secrets
if this caviar is as good as a real
mccoy the proper beluga
then this could be a [ __ ] amazing
find here in spain
it's the water flowing through these
mountains that led the owners of rio
frio caviar to set up a farm here
after a seven year search for the
perfect source
export management fellow brit keith
jaggart will be showing me around
all right gordon how are you nice to
meet you you're right now are you on
half term you look about 12.
now i didn't think it's possible to farm
sturgeon why here in the middle of
[ __ ] spain of all places
the temperature of the water is 13 to 15
degrees all year round and that's
because we have the source of the spring
at 200 meters away from where we're
standing drinkable drinkable and natural
which is a benefit to the sturgeon of
course so are we talking about
as good as wild or better
i i'd say better you've got a big pair
of cohanas you know that i think
honest yes i have [ __ ] me first keith's
taking me to see the tiddlers
that's so ugly yeah yeah so delicious
and delicate
yeah but it'll be eight years before he
can tell the little boys
from the big money girls who can be
anything up to the age of 20 before
their caviar's ready for harvesting
oh god they're everywhere but first
i've got to catch one if you can't grab
the
[Music]
prehistoric distant relatives of the
shark these big mothers are almost 60
kilos and to be examined for caviar
they're wrestled out of the water by
hand
it's absolutely beautiful so how old is
this one this one would probably be
between
18 19 years old for nearly half that
time
the valuable eggs in this fish have been
developing their size and condition are
checked using ultrasound
you can just about see every single egg
i miss honestly identical to going with
your wife for an ultrasound
a little ky jelly rubbing around looking
for the little heartbeat
and oh [ __ ] that's too hard but you say
you've got twins except here we're
looking at what four and a half to five
kilos kilos
of caviar the trick is to catch the eggs
at their optimum quality
before the fish spawns naturally but
this beauty
isn't quite ready yet possibly six
months we'll give it another
another scan right and see how it's
getting on if we just try and turn her
around
yeah come on okay oh [ __ ] okay there you
go and then just slowly push it off just
just very very calmly
when the sturgeon are ready they're
killed and sent for a clinical
extraction
[Music]
this looks like a [ __ ] operating
theater hola
today chief sturgeon surgeon javier is
entrusting me with a scalpel
is that too deep again that's good just
keep going
that's perfect keep going okay let me
see oh [ __ ] i can see kevin
yeah it starts very far down i wish you
told me jesus christ
look at all that caviar in there look at
that
is that all the way up there my god okay
so you can actually see
look at that jesus christ
you see the amount of eggs there look at
all the caviar
it's like a bathtub full of [ __ ]
cabbage how much is in there
i'm surprised you haven't got a security
guard for each sturgeon in there you
know that yeah
under water we don't have security
guards but we have big dogs
do you mind have a little taste please
no go ahead
unbelievable it does need some salt on
there
in terms of flavor [ __ ] how this
extras like a treasure
i couldn't wait to learn how to
transform these freshly harvested eggs
into the delicacy i know and love so
shall we
process process [ __ ] me now i'm going
back home
see you later first the eggs are
separated from the membrane
so you're just gently rubbing it holding
the membrane and we're not bursting the
eggs like this no
that is beautiful what's that worth in
there now keith
talking well over ten thousand pounds oh
my god
they're then rinsed in cold salted
spring water
before sea salt is added to dramatically
enhance the caviar's flavor
you do i don't want to [ __ ] up ten grand
okay
fingers in and just last right yeah
faster faster okay
very creamy for me it doesn't need any
more salt
that's delicious seasoned to perfection
and matured for four months the caviar
in this tin alone will be worth three
and a half grand
thank you thank you thank you pretty
good gracias
this stuff really does give wild caviar
a run for its money and i've got the
perfect recipe to show it off
right lobster and potato salad with the
most amazing mayonnaise and
that special farmed caviar
lobster towels with string as the
lobster cooks tail stays nice and
straight
coat for six to seven minutes bay leaf
lemon lime
fennel star on his coriander bang pop
all the potatoes
once that's cooking mayonnaise add
mustard powder and white wine vinegar to
the egg yolks
whisk whisk whisk slowly add the olive
oil if we don't whisk it enough
it splits now to the exciting part a
little bit of truffle oil
two or three little drops beautiful
lobster out it's nice and straight so
it's a lot easier to slice
slice the potatoes season and drizzle
with olive oil
saute the potatoes and give the lobster
a blast of heat in the pan literally 30
seconds each side
that stops the lobster becoming really
chewy and enhances
the flavor lightly dress the salad and
serve
five nice slices of potato five nice
medallions of lobster a teaspoon
of truffle mayonnaise on the potato
finishing
the salad with this baby look at that
absolutely amazing
my god it has to be the perfect dish for
the last supper a salad of
potato lobster truffle mayonnaise and
the most amazing [ __ ] caviar
[Music]
i've forgotten one nightmare that says
you know that's right mel taylor
and you've got [ __ ] everywhere no it's
not it's not all right touch that
lobster there
stone cold yeah then you go to that as a
hot lobster so
this is most of the most talented
brigade yes right now we're making
biggins look good
i didn't think that was possible what's
that okay now i hope i
ate another one [ __ ] you now
we just dropped
we have to keep going
i'm ready i'm gonna send it out
now that's a thousand pounds worth of
caviar and you just put on the [ __ ]
floor
what's the one thing i asked you not to
do drop the caviar
just come here let me just show you
seriously i want you guys looking good
but if we perform like this we're going
to look [ __ ] stupid and i'm going to
get pissed off
get a grip a bit yeah yeah and focus for
me okay
we need a little time to get used to it
no time a thousand pounds worth of
[ __ ] cover on the floor
[Music]
i've never really had lobster before but
i really enjoyed it and i think
this experience has made me want to eat
fish probably from now on
it's converted me that's nice color on
potatoes there mel
very nice merry lovely
this is it last table and that's the
caviar oh my god there's not even one
egg on any of this
anything on your spoon mary okay very
good
first of all empty plates which looks
great did enjoy your starters
i thought that having never had caviar
before the combination with the lobster
you got that nice salty texture with the
more milder taste of the lobster and
that popping
of the caviar in your mouth i thought it
was delicious
i thought it was nice annoyingly nice
results for the starter please
the number okay i have customers
that are happy to pay for their starter
yes
[Music]
4650
next on the menu i go hunting for puffin
learning how to skyfish in iceland
i'm just worried about standing up on
the side of this
and the starter has gone down well but
the real test has yet to come for the
vegetarian diners
the bill main course i'm quite scared
about eating the veal
i'm really nervous about trying it i was
okay with the lobster
but now with me it's another hurdle to
get through
[Music]
[Applause]
right time for a very special main
course janet's veal
[Music]
british rose veal a really nice
alternative to beef and one of the most
underused meats in the country
seasoned hot pan olive oil
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a very lean meat so they get very
dry quickly
literally 30 seconds each side rest
masala sauce fresh oil in the pan
[Music]
shallots really important to use the
same pan we want that flavour
from the veal being sauteed mushrooms
seasoned color
masala
reduce we're just rinsing the bottom of
the pan out with all that amazing flavor
chicken stock boil
tomatoes tarragon chervil
veal sit back in the sauce
it just adds that really nice rich
sweetness to the flavor of the veal
[Applause]
little treasure chest at british rose
ville
roseville with masala sauce
done we're gonna put out all the stops
and make sure that elton didn't dive all
right
now don't drop the veal i'll try not to
right now mel be careful yeah whatever
you do
don't overcook the veal it cooks very
very quickly both sides in and out it's
a very lean piece of meat hardly any
fats that are overcooked very quickly
don't put the parcel of vinegar in the
bed before everything's killed yes
this will be a meal these diners will
never ever forget for the rest of their
lives
that's all we got to do that's all we
got to do
well done go please
yes that was my first meet in 12 years
and it was it was pretty good actually
i never ever thought veal was something
that i would eat but yeah i'd probably
go for it again
after this it makes you want to sing
when you're doing well we're doing well
definitely i can't believe the way
you're working it's night and day from
the starters
you're not letting elton down thank you
for that
it's amazing what you can get in iceland
these days
for the past 12 weeks i've traveled the
world hunting for the freshest and
finest ingredients
for my final journey i've come to the
end of the [ __ ] earth
iceland is a stunning volcanic melting
pot
on the edge of the arctic circle
it has some of the most extraordinary
beautiful landscapes known to man
and a unique food world to match this
place is home to rotten shark
whale meat and something i've always
wanted to try
puffing here they have a puffin feast on
the menu i'm intrigued to see what it
delivers in terms of texture and flavor
and more importantly i'm dying to find
out what it actually tastes like
i'm sampling a starter of fresh salad
with smoked puffing
thank you and where's the puffin dunny
it's all over here oh
the dark bits see it's hiding in the
bushes again yes it is see
where is it thank you
never tasted anything like it before i
actually quite like it it's
very creamy slightly gamey a little bit
salty
but quite intriguing because it's very
smooth on the palette
and obviously a [ __ ] nightmare to
catch because there's hardly any on my
[ __ ] plate
puffin is such an amazing new ingredient
i'm keen to grill the local chefs about
it
fascinating for me my first time eating
puffin very dark
yeah very dark rich bird yeah and it
smells a little bit like liver it's
quite quite quite dark like a lamborgh
dark beet a little bit like game like
you said yeah and
yeah it really reads flavor i enjoyed it
i'm intrigued by it
thank you having tasted puffing for the
first time i want to find out where they
come from
and learn the age-old way of hunting
them so i'm moving further south i've
seen some airports in my time but
this is taking the piss
[Applause]
i'm heading to the westmon islands 10
miles off iceland's south coast
there are more atlantic puffins on these
remote islands than anywhere else in the
world
[Music]
the birds are a traditional food hunted
for centuries by locals like oliver tier
ollie
hi there hi there good to see you
welcome to westmill islands thank you
now
you look like a little puffy bulky
sturdy
yeah there you go full of stamina yeah
can you fly not really but
i'm always hoping to so you need a lot
of puffins in the uk
yeah everyone right now will be thinking
oh my god they're cute they're beautiful
they're lovely beaks we've got them as
teddy bears for the kids
why in the hell are you eating them well
to begin with a lot of them
around here the four or five million
perfect so they're in abundance
the traditional food in western islands
are the puffins
especially smoked perfect so it goes
back centuries ago in terms of a staple
food supply that the island survived on
yeah yeah and
just tastes very good the method oliver
uses to catch them is hundreds of years
old
what is that thing it's called hour how
howard power yeah well it's close enough
okay let's just call it a pole vault
with a net on the end okay you can call
it whatever you like i called howard
there are no puffings on this open part
of the island so it's perfect for
practicing sky fishing
i would wait for the puffin flying this
way
slowly after they and turn and then
they will fly into the net take the
puffing out
and break the neck have a little go the
bird they're flying that
direction follow follow follow following
back why don't we just get a gun and
shoot them
it's just more of a sport yeah but i
shoot them you catch them in the air
yeah as they fall at this car
the official hunting season doesn't
start until tomorrow which gives me
plenty of time to perfect my swing
got him yeah okay i've got it
and cook another part of my puffing menu
a traditional icelandic bread
right i'm going to make a really nice
rustic bread to go with the puffins for
tomorrow
i'm adding yeast to rye flour wholemeal
flour salt and sugar
a little well in the center add the milk
in three stages
knead the dough until firm and that's
what we're looking for
that really nice smooth beautiful
rustic dough into the tin
i'm finishing the bread with blowderg a
traditional icelandic flower
when you rub them together it releases
amazing oil it's a sort of cross between
lavender and rosemary as that
cooks it's going to perfume the bread
smells amazing lid on now i'm gonna bake
that bread
in the biggest oven i've ever seen in my
entire [ __ ] life
[Music]
this is mount elfell a volcano that
erupted and changed the face of the
islands
just 35 years ago with the crater still
hot enough
to bake a loaf
[Music]
so this is the oven and the deeper you
go yep the hotter it is yes
honestly when that is absolutely
incredible ah the heat yeah i feel how
hot that is
it's extraordinary how long
in the other two hours yeah only the
vikings were thinking about digging deep
under a volcanic rock hardberg being a
baker yeah but i mean how do i put the
work in especially not paying for the
gas
the bread will bake overnight and
tomorrow the official puffing hunting
season on the westman islands
will begin
one two
grandma three i'm very well good to see
you welcome to the f-word thank you very
much
enjoy your food now are you being
sparing with elton because not enough to
go around well we've got 50 desserts
yes and that's a big no he's a calf
that's why he's real
exactly that
think about the poor calves having to
put up with janet's reported for that
length of time in fairness
was it an abattoir or suicide
jumping in there but you've never been
vegetarian no god no no never thought
about it
not really no because i don't you know i
think it's dead now
yeah so you know don't say that too
there's a lot of them in tonight you
know that oh
yeah yeah now you excited about the rest
of the challenge
you know i am because i well i i'm
nervous as well
right because clearly you're gordon
ramsay you know i'm nervous too i mean i
i have one more
now you used to be a waiter i did yeah
for how long uh probably
all together about eight or nine years
good let's see if that big mouth of
yours can still please the punters yeah
okay a good waiter sells the specials
of the restaurant professionally yes
sell this aperitif
to the table this is a lovely pair of
teeth called [ __ ]
there have some of that that's lovely
in fairness it's been a while since i've
tasted this
but i know it's very popular
with many people uh uh gordon you'd like
to try that what's so good about this
drink
this well it's got some natural energy
in the [ __ ]
go on taste your [ __ ]
did you like that is it good
um you're going to try something as well
all right i'll taste a little bit okay
yeah it's a bit like your beer it hasn't
changed my mind
[Laughter]
i thought that actually meat would be
something that i would
really detest but actually i find it's
fantastic yeah how was your feel young
man
would it be bad to say really good i'm
so pleased you know that it was an
amazing journey to get them
to the table but i feel really bad
because i haven't eaten meat for such a
long time how long
20 years 20 years yeah you didn't look
that old
how old are you 26 and you've never
eaten meat in 20 years i had a
bacon sandwich about four years ago and
that's it that's it that's fantastic
news
i just think 20 years all those
vegetables no wonder your hair's so
curly
extraordinary i'm so pleased we've
converted you
i really really like the beer i really
think compliments a meal
dougal nice to see you sir you're
looking very smart
so now that for me was an amazing
journey
yes how was the experience for you
drinking it
alongside the veal i think in this
particular case you got a lot of
sweetness there
in the beer and the veal for me was
sweet it had a caramel flavor on the
outside
and the two complemented each other
beautifully yeah and there's that oaky
character just a little hint of that
sort of
vanilla yeah i think the whole lot went
together beautifully better than the
wine i thought
thank you for your help with that
that is delicious um good to see you
thank you so much
hi tom hello janet hi john well done
yeah tremendous veal yeah the veal
tastes great delicious
tom did enjoy the beer i thought it was
a good bit it was definitely a
proper ale yeah it wasn't a lager it was
definitely a sopping in a country park
right results in main course tough out
there 50 vegetarians
they're not just normal punters they've
arrived here this evening
to have meat for the first time in years
and i'm not talking about six seven
eight months i'm talking about years
five
ten sometimes fifteen twenty years
okay the number of people
that are willing to pay look is
46 out of 50. that is amazing
that is amazing you definitely did not
let elton down
well done coming up
i go back to the field of dreams where
my football career started
home and ended there's some fantastic
memories and there's some tragic
memories
and graham norton's making a peach of a
dessert in the recipe challenge
i'm going to make a delicious roast
peach and amaretto dessert as gordon
might say it's sweet juicy and full of
flavor
[Music]
[Applause]
right it's recipe challenge time and
tonight's challenger is comedian
presenter national treasure graham
norton but
there's more at stake because whichever
dessert the blind tasters choose
will be served to all the diners so are
you ready i'm very ready what are you
doing
basically it's a roast baked peaches
rice with
um amoresso and lavender here's one i
made earlier i'm gonna make a delicious
roast peach and amaretto dessert as
gordon might say it's sweet
juicy and full of flavor boiling water
peel slice them in two take out a little
pity bit
that's quite hard to do [ __ ] look
after that there you go
bowl amaretto maple syrup sugar
slop that around a bit perhaps i should
have tasted that
let's find it tray pour the oven
five minutes already lavender
oven five minutes out
plate creme fraiche amaretti biscuits
lavender delicious roast peaches with
amaretto dessert
done so graham's doing a roasted peach
stroke
braised peach with lavender yeah some of
the oven
in the oven yeah oven cooked served on a
plate
what do you want blood gordon served on
i thought it sounds as delicious as it
was so graham's doing the dish
roasted peaches with lavender served on
a plate with amaretti biscuits
i'm gonna smartass roasted peaches with
a delicious lemon and lime and basil
creme fresh
water sugar boil take your knives
peaches basil
poach take them out of the syrup
peel and the stone should just fall out
syrup gramanio boil
icing sugar into the oven six to seven
minutes
to beautifully roast creme fraiche
lemon zest lime zest
basil mix
marzipan roll out your marzipan nice and
thin
cut glaze
assemble creme fresh marzipan
[Music]
[Applause]
peach out the oven onto the creme
fraiche and sit
the other half on top raspberry cooley
toasted almonds roasted peaches with
lemon lime and basil creme fresh
done now why didn't you choose this dish
because i tried it in a restaurant all
night and this was delicious
yeah and i thought very simple i could
probably cook this yeah
and do you get a chance to cook at home
cooking's fun when there's time to do it
yes do you mean because it's lovely
having people over but if it's stressful
what's the point
so you're gonna blanch them first in
like uh i've done that syrup
peel them yeah doing it so you don't
like skin
you don't like the skin of the peaches
so it looks like you made some effort
you actually did this is the only bit of
cooking involved the brigade will be so
happy
if i win because it is a piece of piss
now used to be a waiter i did yes were
you a good waiter uh
i sometimes i started off being good and
then
you just you know people are making fun
and you say it's your [ __ ] dinner
you'll eat again you know but where's
our food i'm guessing it's in the
kitchen
i don't have it did you ever thicken
anybody's vinaigrette when you're pissed
off with a customer
we did do something horrible to
somebody's coffee once
we did something in the cafeteria before
we put the hot water in and we just did
it behind the bar so like someone could
have seen us do it what exactly did he
do there was might have been a little
piss in the coffee
but the wrong person drank it
the restaurant the restaurant is shot
now but it's not our fault okay good
yeah
yeah a little touchy grime on you oh
the old grandma oh yeah yeah over the
top and then a little bit of the sort of
cooking juice
do you like to take food to the bedroom
is it something you sort of no
no no no i mean it's fine in hotels yes
i think sex hotels is very different to
sex at home yes
sex at home someone's got to clean this
up you know laundry will be done
yeah i remember trying to be romantic
once with rose petals they staying the
[ __ ] out of sheets
it looked like i killed someone
are you romantic um i try seriously but
not really no
no see because how long have you been
married now uh 11 years
11 11 years i know see that's a mystery
to me a mystery in terms of
of just staying with someone for 11
years really i sat outside i didn't know
people last night they were married for
25 years 25 years
25 and what was that what what was the
the secret behind that one i didn't ask
oh well actually the secret is that the
husband is denzel washington
who's going to leave him right
off you go top and bottom uh just in
there
[Laughter]
look at you just like that
excellent right i'm going on top they go
in the oven we come back
and we find out which desserts can be
served to the diners
are you confident you know quietly
confident that doesn't look as good as i
thought it would
you [ __ ] now i'm taking my fight for
health eating
back to my old stomping ground
as a boy i dreamt of playing
professional football for my favorite
local team
glasgow rangers
[Music]
my dream came true when i was spotted by
a scout in the mid-80s and i joined the
youth team here at ibrox
[Music]
i've got so many great memories
including playing alongside one of
scotland's football legends
koisi perhaps one of the most recognized
one of the most famous players ever
to grace the field at ibrox mccoy making
the run
and a marvelous opening goal remember
them well and the one thing that's stuck
here but gone the one
that's never ever changed and never will
change he's a he's a competitor of
so-and-so that wants to
want to do the best and be the best they
can
wow home sweet home beautiful
there's some fantastic memories and
there's some tragic memories
there's no other club like it anywhere
in the world
wow the terrible memories were coming
through those main doors and being sent
upstairs to the bosses office
and to be told that you're no longer
part of rangers
that's a big kick in the bollocks trust
me i got released on the back of an
injury
um smashed my cartilage and then they
said they'd keep an eye on me but
that's just a polite [ __ ] off really
that's all
[Music]
do you know what any form of pain that i
experienced here
was eradicated when i won my third
michigan star and had i not had
the upset in football here with ibrox i
don't think i'll be the chef i am today
when i played we ate steak and chips pie
and beans and training was basic
run till you drop now that's all changed
for the better
but football astringent diets can be
bland and most of them have never set
foot in the kitchen which is something
i'd like to change
i'm at murray park rangers training
ground i meet my old friend alan mccoy
to see what they're up to
hopefully hasn't put too much weight on
oh never
mind your watch boy how are you doing
you've lost weight i've washed the beef
actually
since you gave me that telling off last
time i'll show you my happy to be here
what are you training yeah we're gonna
give our training about work and stuff
then i joined the squad for a full-on
training session
times like this when you seriously get
to understand how much you miss it
followed by three punishing quick fire
[Music]
matches
training over i'm joining ali for an
infamous rangers routine
the ice tub
[Applause]
i've got the perfect thing to warm our
frozen cockles a tasty hot lunch for the
lads that should prove healthy food
doesn't need to be bland and boring
right i'm in the kitchens of murray park
here coy so you know and this man bay
folks and captain of rangers and
scotland when's the last time you're in
the kitchen
mike was the two two years all right so
i'm going to do the most amazing
chicken dish poached and sauteed chicken
breast
harika bean salad and balsamic roasted
fennel
we're kicking off with the fennel cut
into quarters smell it add a seed
lovely nice and fresh fragrant seasoned
drizzled olive oil and balsamic vinegar
you never cook at home
no yeah my way you've cooked straight
into the oven
200 degrees 12 to 15 minutes does it get
any harder
yes it does move your ass chicken breast
free range high in protein low in fat
just what these players need to keep
them running we're just going to poach
them now for six minutes half a bowl of
garlic a little bit of thyme rosemary
make the chicken
a lot more fragrant we're just trying to
make it more exciting yeah
and no sauces no cream no butter and
something you can get up and feel
energized with
gonna make a vinaigrette berry right
okay mustard olive oil
balsamic vinegar go easy on the salt
because that dehydration even quicker
now for the second half bean salad beans
packed with protein olives help to
season and stop them becoming a little
bit bland a couple of tablespoons of
vinaigrette this is baby spinach yeah
packed with iron
tossed with basil leaves and a splash of
the dressing
chicken out and skin side down
i never thought i'd see the day
scotland's captain and the most prolific
goal scorer arranges ever golden food
in front of the stove hey what you don't
have that sweat on gordon yeah don't
sweat in the chicken though
anyone complains about it being [ __ ]
salty i know who to blame
half a ladle of stock in there that's
gonna act almost like a bit of a sauce
really
crispy skin yeah nice moist chicken
inside drizzle the roasted fennel with
vinaigrette
to serve a handful of spinach salad and
just sit
the fennel on top get a nice even
distribution of the beans
and the olives slice the chicken
and spoon on some vinaigrette here we go
you know what they're gonna say they
don't like it whether they like it
[Music]
so ally you can do that again for the
guys i would do that again for the voice
yes good good good good
coming up i'm back in stunning iceland
[Music]
on the edge of a cliff risking life and
limb to hunt for puffing
i'm [ __ ] myself relax be part of the
nature
[Applause]
right welcome back now time to find out
the results of the recipe challenge and
which dessert
will be served to our diners that does
look quite nice though it does look
quite nice
i'm a big fan of the white place but i
think for a dessert you can go a bit
colorful
right jose good luck graeme dan to you
sir
yes your hands are all sticky of course
they are i'm covering maple syrup
hello
i really think the texture of the peach
is quite nice
cream works very well with the pink i
like the almonds in there yeah i love
the love of the fragrance it's really
nice
and the presentation is absolutely
terrific
i think this is presented a bit nicely
in the last
dish and much for further source than
having the lavender
i think it works a lot better i actually
find that the sauce a bit too sharp in
this one
i actually prefer the previous one with
the honey
i get nervous about this [ __ ] yeah i'm
a little bit nervous no because
those little bits of lavender flowers
last challenge of the series
okay oh look at that face and i don't
look i don't know what that means
how did it go down well it was close oh
god it always softens it with that one
this people comes in gives it a low blow
so
what do they say about them well they
did like the marzipan and the raspberry
and yours of course they would yeah nice
but they like the the balance of flavor
from green sponsor forget the balance
whose dessert is getting served to the
diners come on
if you want a job jose come on come on
don't look at him like that i'm going
yeah
i'm sorry granny yeah well done
look at that place i'm so strong no i'm
still going to do that i'll still be
cooking at home
i don't care i don't care i can't
believe they like marzipan i thought
your dish was delicious
thank you very much a little bit too
much alcohol for me but it was delicious
um
oh that's so not true never enough it's
been a pleasure
it's been a pleasure being here and i
just feel sorry for the brigade now
to cook your really dreadery complicated
dessert
right do me a favor yeah [ __ ] about my
kitchen now
goodbye thank you goodbye cheers gordon
thank you graeme yes
i've traveled 1 200 miles to the westmon
islands off the south coast of iceland
to hunt a delicious
local delicacy puffin
it's the first day of the season and to
catch them we're heading even further
afield to one of ollie's best hunting
spots
so where are we going to hunt the
puffins uh it's on the other side of the
island
yeah in the middle no not in the middle
on the edge
on the edge yeah what do you mean like
that
[ __ ] olly you're mad
this is eck liver a one of the westman's
14 uninhabited islands
it was difficult to access from the
water and having clambered to the top
for an hour
i couldn't quite believe where i ended
up
[Music]
we're perched on the edge of a cliff
with an 80 meter drop into the north
atlantic ocean
i'm [ __ ] myself relax be part of the
nature
the puffins circle the edge catching the
wind and it didn't take long for ollie
to show me exactly how it's done
yep yeah ah that was quick
yep hold the leg width hold it like that
under the wings yes under the wings the
first one of the season
is released ready beautiful you're one
lucky little
[ __ ] like my [ __ ] nose
it lags you know [ __ ]
[ __ ] slice my nose you little bastard
ready
yeah and go that's the last time i'm
kissing a [ __ ] puffin
i start [ __ ] around we're on the side
of a cliff huh
at 250 feet this wasn't going to be easy
very close very close i'm just worried
about standing up on the side of this
well you shouldn't worry too much no
forget that together
ollie makes sky fishing look easy but i
spent three hours on the cliff without
catching a thing
it's lit is far there's no way on earth
i can go home with a big [ __ ] cut on
my nose and no puffins trust me
it's a lot more difficult than i thought
it would be moving to the other side of
the island
we were hoping our luck might change oh
i was not letting that one go okay no
chance
you want stuff jesus christ almighty
huh it had taken
five hours but i'd finally got the hang
of it
fantastic that was high that one that's
good
very good puffing number two we could
have gone on catching for hours
but i only needed a couple of puffins to
cook with so i decided to set my third
one free
i'm gonna let this one go first day of
the season
[Applause]
you got two i got two that's a good
number that's a good number
let's go back on the main island ollie
showed me the best way to de-breast the
birds
just break snap and break yep
right and then do it like this it's
ready to do
that's incredible yeah in here you have
the heart the heart yeah yeah you want
one would you eat that
iceland's very own hannibal lecter then
it was my turn
oh you have a heart as well ollie come
on come on
don't be a chicken it's a puffin you're
bitten by one and then you can eat it
doesn't taste bad
oh [ __ ] i can't believe you just made me
that hard
right hannibal let me show you how to
cook them [ __ ] properly you stay here
yeah i look forward to this unbelievable
the volcanic bread i made yesterday
turned out to be a big hit with the
locals because overnight
it got nicked but it was the puffing i
was here for
and i couldn't wait to cook with it
marinade puffing breast
in brenovin take the breast off the bone
[Music]
just a tad larger than a pigeon breast
but
a hundred times tastier i'm making a
marinade for the puffing with crushed
juniper berries
salt pepper and olive oil two-thirds
olive oil
and one-third brennervin brennevin is a
local liqueur
like a schnapps
mmm lovely and then puffin straight into
the marinade
whilst the puffin marinades i'm making a
salad with skir
an icelandic yogurt cucumber garlic and
mint
the nice thing about this cucumber salad
it cools down the richness
of the puffing just slice
through the breast get your rosemary
twig push it through
and the nice thing about that as it
cooks it perfumes inside that puffing
breast
it's a very lean bird so i don't want
this thing to dry out
for the barbecue cherry tomatoes on the
vine drenched with olive oil and
balsamic vinegar
and now for the puffing straight on the
barbecue
[Music]
lovely literally one minute each side
and once i barbecue them they're going
back in the marinade
nice bread now unfortunately
bread got nicked last night so this is
what olly cooked at his house
the tomatoes just sat on the bread skin
cucumber salad and then this our puffing
breast
just pull out the rosemary wow
that is delicious and that is our
perfect puffin
fit for any [ __ ] viking oli's invited
his sons down to see if my puffin
passes the test i'm dying to see what
you think in terms of flavor
have you ever eaten it that rare nope
this tastes much better than i ever
expected really
yeah good man for me the flavour of
puffing is unique
i love it and here's the good news yeah
now i've got my license
yeah i'm coming back you've got your
laser
yes then we have a real competition
[Music]
the sharpness of the peaches and the
cooling
just went really well with the sweet
marzipan which is brilliant
a little mini explosion of happiness in
my mouth i don't think i'm exaggerating
when i say this is [ __ ]
time for the results for the dessert
right the number of diners
that are willing to pay for the dessert
is
43 out of 50. well done you got 135
out of 150 jose champagne please let's
go
well done thank you well good luck with
the bacon sandwiches tomorrow
you